je reçois maintenant charlotte
gainsbourg pour la sortie en salle de la
bûche le film de danièle thompson dont
soir charlotte alors la bûche de données
thomson donc avec sabine azéma
emmanuelle béart françoise fabian claude
rich christopher thompson et françoise
brion et darroussin françoise briand que
j'ai j'ai reconnu avec toutes ces années
alors l'histoire c'est quoi c'est une
histoire de famille quelques jours avant
noël avec on rentre dans l'univers de
chaque soeur en fait il ya trois soeurs
et les parents évidemment
et si une ambiance un peu moi c'est
chaque histoire personnelle c'est les
jeux 3 sort très différente c'est à dire
que vous vous êtes un peu la russie
s'est très bien dans l'informatique vous
êtes plutôt la révolte est fait de la
moto vous êtes libre comme on s'en doute
quelques clichés du terme
emmanuelle béart et c'est là la
bourgeoise voilà et puis azéma c'est
l'artiste un peu l'un c'est ça et
françoise fabian c'est donc la mère des
trois filles a été mariée avant avec
claude rich et puis elle son mari actuel
qui son mari du moment qui meurent au
début du film
oui et film commence on peut raconter la
scène faut pas raconter la fin on peut
raconter la scène du début
c'est génial c'est l'enterrement du mari
de françoise fabian donc le beau père de
trois filles qui sont tous au cimetière
et puis un portable qui sonne puis tout
le monde fait comme ça et puis en fait
c'est le portable du mort c'est un très
beau film je trouve vraiment très
touchant avec des dialogues formidable
avec des vrais mots des vrais mots
d'auteur de très bons comédiens un peu
une ambiance un peu à la cloud sauter un
peu qu'on retrouvait dans le film de
benoît jacquot pas de scandale c'est à
dire en ce moment il ya en france comme
ça un cinéma un peu classique qui
revient non pour toi moi je sais pas si
c'est un film classique mais je sais pas
moi je sais j'en suis vraiment fier
c'est un film qui me touche qui me fait
rire beaucoup
donc non je suis contente en plus de
faire partie de ces la première fois que
je fais un film avec autant d'acteurs et
où on partage vraiment tous le film cm
une âme ouais et la fin surtout pas
raconter mais la fin est très très
étonnant comment ça s'est passé parce
que c'était quand même même si elle est
longtemps été scénariste de son père de
gérard oury c'était quand même le
premier film de
thomson sont sur le plateau ça allait
n'était pas trop j'ai pas eu
l'impression elle faisait ce qu'elle
faisait son premier film en fait
enfin oui elle était elle était très à
l'aise mais elle savait exactement ce
qu'elle voulait donc non je me sentais
très en confiance avec elle j'ai avec
les autres secteurs parce que c'était
c'est vrai que c'était c'était vraiment
j'ai eu une expérience géniale hockey
sont très bien dirigés ils sont mieux de
leur forme
alors ça fait penser au noël quand on
quand on était petits vous souvenez de
vaud noël parce que moi j'ai lu que vous
preniez le train pour la londe revoir
vos grands parents maternels dans des
couchettes communicante alors c'est
vraiment la nuit magique vous prenez le
bateau
prenez le train de nuit c'était un
moment j'ai des souvenirs ouais vraiment
magique de londres sous la neige est
enfin pour les enfants c'est c'est eh
c'est des beaux souvenirs bon laisser
voulait absolument que dans le
compartiment laisse la las vegas ali
mais parce que vous dites le noir mais
terrifiée je croyais devenir aveugle
j'ai dit c'est vrai vous êtes-vous dit
souvent derrière cette angoisse et de
naissance ça va mieux que ça
ouais beaucoup beaucoup mieux cette cire
un plateau non détendez vous c'est pas
c'est dû à votre vous pensez que cette
angoisse que vous accompagnez un peu
longtemps comme ça on sait que c'est dû
à une enfance un peu brinquebalée je
dirais votre mère qui faisait dans des
boîtes
moi j'ai fait part avec mes enfants
c'est pas un reproche mais à l'âge de 2
ans vous retrouviez dans une boîte de
nuit où dormir sur la banquette est ce
que vous croyez que ça c'est à
participer à votre angoisse mais nous
contraire ça c'est dans sa jeunesse
c'est ce qu'il y avait mieux et puis
mais il n'y avait pas que ça on est y
avait eu une éducation pas rigide mais
presque une bonne solidarité ce que
serge appelé la bande des quatre
quand j'arrive quand même à un côté mais
c'est pas ça qui vous a en fait je
dirais non j'ai une soeur
ma petite soeur qui ya eu le même genre
d'éducation et a priori qu aucune
angoisse voilà je la connais nom n'a pas
le même tempérament donc non c'est pas
ce fait pas partie de l'éducation je
crois pas mais votre horloge biologique
elle va mieux parce qu'avant vous disiez
que vous y restez éveillés 48 heures et
puis derrière 48 heures sans cesse en
maintenant j'ai vieilli donc je tiens
moi le coup ouais je dis colérique ont
visé petite que l'âge de 12 ans
maintenant ça s'est calmé ça je pense
alors c'est très marrant la façon vous
êtes rentré dans le cinéma parce qu'en
84 un jour votre mère jane birkin vous
la laisse un mot sur la table en disant
aux tablas cuisant dans les choix qui
cherchent une ado de ton âge l'asie pour
voir et bouge et a laissé passer
commande ce casting je sais pas je
serais curieuse de voir en fait les
images mais je pense qu'il les a perdus
j'ai le souvenir d'avoir été très
traqueuse et j'ai pas si j'ai pu sortir
un mot mais il m'a choisi je sais pas
enfin chez pas il a dû se passer quelque
chose quand ils savaient qu'ils vous
étiez vous non oui ça va non mes choix
j'espère qu'ils m'avaient appris que
pense un bel avenir à prouver le
contraire est alors en 84 c'est donc
dans la même époque vous demandez à
partir en pension en suisse pourquoi
vous vous vous aviez un manque
d'autorité à la maison vous avez envie
d'une vie plus facturer c'est possible
j'ai pas j'ai pas vraiment analyser mais
ouais j'avais c'est ça faisait partie
aussi des fantasmes que parce que ma
mère a fait de la pension quand elle
était petite
ma belle mère aussi enfin genre de
pensions donc ça me tentait ma soeur
aussi très bonne parce que en fait
l'expérience des autres elle était
plutôt très négatif vous avez tous
détestés en général des gens qui
demandent à leurs fonctions il n'a pu y
aller alors bon en 85 ans tu l'aimés
lindsay ce jeudi est pas là vous étiez
soi-disant scandale pas vécu parce que
vous étiez vous étiez en pension vous
êtes passé à côté de cette histoire est
quand même c'est vrai qu'avec l'inceste
il ya eu après vous ai fait ce film avec
votre oncle encore king jardin de ciment
est là dans le film pour en venir à la
bûche dans le film finalement on va pas
raconter d'histoires en fait quand même
quelque chose qui peut qui pourrait
peut-être il ressemble et d'une certaine
façon oui oui c'est vrai oui enfin si
elle est consommée l'inceste dans le
jardin de six mois
là il ya une ambiguïté menominee tc3
faut alors 85 fait les fronts
l'effrontée donc césar en 86 points film
vous allez tourner à 14 ans qui est
absolument extraordinaire
alors dans les résultats quand on disait
charlotte et les charmes du val-andré
qui devait avoir des décès vous attendez
charlotte vous avez fait passer un grand
moment sur
jeudi on avait tous les larmes aux yeux
quand je vous le dis parce que j'ai revu
les images des sages des images
exceptionnelles
quand on voit serge quilly maxima petit
fils et ma petite fille c'est vraiment
tout le monde tout le monde pleurait
devant la télé soit alors après les
faits la petite voleuse un cheat
quelques filles parce que c'est vrai
qu'à noël beaucoup les yeux au jeu du
monde je vais rencontrer
sylvain attal yvan attal pardon et merci
la vie donc qui a été votre imac blier
ou pitié c'est extraordinaire c'était un
beau film c'est un très beau fils
j'ai fait du théâtre ouais ouais il a dû
falloir vous sont surmontées enfin vous
dépassez terriblement parce que quand
même la salle années nous étions un peu
timide un peu c'était autre chose
j'avais très peur d'avoir un trac qui me
paralyserait au contraire c'était pas
non j'ai découvert un travail
nouveau est génial avec maurice bénichou
nous fait de travailler pendant 2 -
comme ça sur scène en fait quand vous
arriviez avant au cinéma comme vous avez
un certain don vous jouiez assez
naturellement est là pour la première
fois vous avez travaillez vous avez
répété oui c'est la première fois que je
comprenais ce qui était d une
préparation en fait ce qui me ce qui
après m'a permis de de préparer les
rôles sur d'autres films différemment
oui c'est une bonne école oui parce que
vous vous avez essayé un moment de
prendre des cours donc ça c'était à la
natte david mamet sur scène après grosse
fatigue jenner et puis en 97 vit donc un
enfant est ce que vous êtes devenu
adulte en ayant un enfant annoncé ma
rage à nice
bon oui moi ça vous ça vous a rajeuni
ouais je me sens un toit mais je n'ai
pas la sensation d'avoir d'avoir pris un
coup de vieux
alors la décision de devenir comédienne
un jour d'être sur un plateau vous
saviez pas vraiment voulu devenir que
les comédiennes jane birkin vous emmener
partout avec elle et vous regardez leur
mars a quitté le tournage de la pirate
de doillon donc votre beau-père et vous
gêne vous dit que vous avez porté sur
leur marsac un regard un peu de jalousie
oui c'est ce qu'elle dit je veux bien la
croire c'est très possible mais à mon
avis c'était pareil
j'avais pas un désir d'être comédienne
et c'était plus c'était plus d'avoir
envie que l'attention soit sur moi je
crois via les voulez qu'on vous avez
quoi bon vous alors muller a dit en
parlant de vous claude miller et qu'ils
aient fait parmi vos mii un film a dit
en parlant de vous que vous êtes une
actrice née comme mozart était un
musicien né ouais vous pensez ça non
nous n'avons pas du tout est-ce qu'à
l'époque où vous avez joué au premier
film vous le dis assez naturellement
d'une façon un peu inconsciente sans
réfléchir
oui avait beaucoup d'inconscience et
puis je faisais ça surtout pour faire
plaisir en fait c'était pas j'avais pas
du tout la notion de travail ça c'est
venu après ouais donc comme ça au
sérieux
ouais j'essaie de ne pas trop me prendre
au sérieux au sérieux je vous rassure
mais vous disais toujours à l'époque je
suis pas une vraie actrice c'est
pourquoi parce que vous aviez peur pour
qu'on vous propose plus drôle est comme
ça au moins où jean sortie bien où je
crois que j'avais peur du jugement
ouais je me cachais derrière un truc où
je pouvais me permettre de dire si
jamais ça fonctionnait pas que c'était
pas évident je suis rarement fier de ce
que je fais j'ai toujours quelque chose
à me reprocher angoissé de naissance on
a vu tout à l'heure en même temps je
suis fier de mon nom et j'ai envie
d'être à la hauteur
ça va mieux maintenant d'être prêt quand
même un peu d'assurance non non pas
passer enfin pas suffisamment pour me
sentir à l'aise comme j'aimerais l'être
en tout cas sur 1 sur un plateau c'est
ça me demande beaucoup de travail de
m'approprier pas les gens mais de me
sentir à l'aise dans la rue ça peut
remettre pour vous parce que c'est vrai
que vous vous savez du bien d'être
quelqu'un d'autre j'ai toujours éprouvé
un certain malaise à être moi même temps
quand on joue en général c'est pour pour
s'oublier pour eux c'est la même chose
maintenant que je prends du plaisir -
une bonne thérapie
oui dernière chose votre père disait que
j'étais une orchidée déguisé en orties
ça vous fait ça vous fait quoi enfin je
veux dire en dehors du fait ça celui
qu'il l'ait dit bien sûr mais vous
trouvez que c'est un compliment
oui c'est un compliment je sais pas si
je suis pas si les il est valable pour
moi mais c'est un compliment
merci beaucoup merci d'être venu charles
suis très content des corrections de ne
rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
émettez un pouce bleus